straight hello from never ceases cameras
or clouds form architecture commands
everyone i am going to answer a question
on corruption how can new leaders try
and resist or eliminate corruption and
developing countries our organizations
corruption is one of the major things we
have to face well we do a lot of
construction work in developing copies
so and as a result in order to implement
a new come across a lot of internal
external corruption the only way you can
do it is to be as open as transparent as
possible and you have to basically
everything all your data online we live
in a kind of world where we talk about
personal privacy and the lack of
personal privacy but in a way you can
actually use it for good in business so
when we're talking about corruption in
in developing countries it's not just
outside the country I mean inside the
countries outside cut yourself look at
eight thirty percent of eight doesn't
even make the country so how do we make
sure that there's a player on
transparent system you put up all
budgets you show visual documentation of
projects and you allow the community to
have a stake in SA so that means if
you're building a housing
project for 2,000 families give every
one of those families live video or
access to a mobile phone so they can
basically respond to any issues they see
on the ground so i would say utilize
technology in a way that will publish
these issues before they become too big
because corruption happens behind closed
doors at the end i carry bubbles